même en période de pique tout cela est
sous contrôle une visite pour rassurer
la ministre de la transition énergétique
Agnès panier rue naché était au centre
de répartition de l'électricité sur le
site rte de Montigny-le-Bretonneux en
pleine crise énergétique la femme
politique est venue échanger avec les
collaborateurs du site objectif aborder
les enjeux de l'hiver ce qui ressort de
ces scénarios c'est que compte tenu du
volume d'électricité et de gaz sur
lequel on peut compter dans les cas
divers normaux classiques avec le plan
sobriété nous devrait et la solidarité
européenne d'après la ministre
l'Allemagne la Belgique l'Espagne ou
encore le Royaume-Uni feront preuve de
solidarité en cas de difficulté mais des
efforts collectifs à plus basse échelle
doivent être fait afin d'appréhender au
mieux cette période il faut une
mobilisation nationale
des collectivités des entreprises et des
Français déjà pour éviter de consommer
ce qui est inutile tous les jours parce
que ça ça fera baisser la consommation
et nous on le verra et puis ça évitera
d'aller
trop consommer des stocks de gaz qui
sont rares ça évitera d'aller consommer
d'eau dans les barrages donc ça c'est
toujours bon à prendre s'il n'y a pas de
spécificité régionale des actions sont
menées dans les Yvelines nous avons mis
en place ce dispositif Ecowatt dont
l'objectif est de sensibiliser
l'ensemble des consommateurs donc c'est
les particuliers mais aussi les
entreprises et les collectivités au fait
que ils peuvent par l'adoption
d'éco-gestes réduire leur consommation
d'électricité et
rendre plus facile le passage de l'hiver
à venir à noter que RTE a avancé sa
période de vigilance à octobre dans les
Yvelines des décisions devraient être
annoncées dans les jours à venir afin de
réaliser davantage d'économies d'énergie
pendant l'hiver